hey have you seen Patrick around
he's the one he's got he's got like a
big head
oh yeah he's in the back he's trying to
get a head on his head it's not his head
he's big isn't it these are problems
that only people with big heads will
understand there's a few different types
of big heads there's people with round
big heads there's people with optical
illusion big heads where up front that
looks normal
but then I turn to the side and oh my
god who saw that coming
you realize things were only made for
people with normal-sized ads like
helmets ooh
here try these on and sunglasses hats
are the devil anyone with a big guy can
tell you that wearing a head makes you
figure wearing a yarmulke fitted hats
are terrible snap eggs are by far the
worst having one snap is the most
embarrassing thing about wearing this
hat all the other kids look great but
your mom had to attach extra holes so it
would fit and it wasn't even the
matching color and people with
normal-sized heads don't get funny it's
not funny sorry I'm sorry the one thing
that does make you what big has feel
better is the fact that famous people
have big heads like Jay Leno Alec
Baldwin Eaters Elba Angelina Jolie Tyra
Banks Rihanna and Nicolas Cage so the
fact that those people went through this
means that there's hope for all of us
hang in there big head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]